dhaussy régler pour les gardiens de
prison donc en revanche le conflit des
infirmières se durcit les négociations
avec les syndicats ne reprendront que
lundi prochain une grève est prévue
d'ores et déjà pour jeudi prochain 13
octobre mais le plus important
aujourd'hui c'est qu'en dehors des
syndicats officiels qui ne sont que
partiellement représentatif il faut le
signaler dans cette corporation
la coordination parisienne des
infirmières s'est transformée
aujourd'hui en coordination nationale et
appellent à cesser le travail dès lundi
d'ailleurs dans certains établissements
la grève n'avait jamais réellement cessé
françois jeu le plus important service
des urgences de paris l'hôtel dieu
cet après-midi des malades et accidentés
sont hospitalisés aussitôt admis ils
sont prises en charge par des infirmiers
et des infirmières en grève
réquisitionnés car aujourd'hui dans cet
hôpital la grève continue et c'est au
moins le cas dans plusieurs
établissements de la région parisienne
une grève spontanée alors que ni les
syndicats ni la coordination n'avait
appelé aujourd'hui à la poursuite d'une
bulle gens ne sont pas du tout décidé
arrêté un logement qui effectivement
très important parce que nous n'avons
rien eu des infirmiers infirmières très
mobilisés qui se sont réunis en
coordination nationale toute la journée
à la sorbonne
là on a décidé de reconduire la grève à
partir de lundi
autre décision une manifestation
nationale jeudi à paris un mouvement des
infirmières qui revendique toujours son
autonomie par rapport aux syndicats et
qui demandent plus que jamais à être
reconnue par les pouvoirs publics
de répéter que la profession infirmière
n'est pas syndiquée pratiquement pas
donc
moyens d'existence aujourd'hui c'est au
travers de cette phobie nation donc le
moyen de prouver aujourd'hui à vaincre
sur le plan national
arrivé à déterminer quelle est
réellement notre représentativité
ce sera pas blanche au niveau des
fédérations syndicales et pour le
gouvernement par être reconnue et enfin
entendus lundi les négociations
reprennent entre les syndicats et le
ministre de la santé claude evin le
gouvernement qui a débloqué jeudi
dernier un milliard de francs pour cette
profession encore fait quelques
propositions lierre mais des
propositions jugées toujours très
insatisfaisante par les syndicats et les
infirmières